Mank?
It's Orson Welles.
Of course it is.
I think it's time we talked.
What is it the writer says?
"Tell the story you know."
Hello, everyone.
Make yourself to home, Mr. Mankiewicz.
Or shall I call you Herman?
-Please, call me Mank.
-Mank.
This is Herman Mankiewicz,
but we have to call him Mank.
Mankiewicz?
Herman Mankiewicz,
New York playwright and drama critic?
Turned humble screenwriter. Mr. Hearst.
This is a business where the buyer
gets nothing for his money but a memory.
What he bought
still belongs to the man who sold it.
-That's the real magic of the movies.
-Action!
Thunder, lightning, blood,
fire, religion...
Help! Someone save me!
All in one film?
That's director-proof.
That's why I always want Mank around.
I hear you're hunting dangerous game.
God bless William Randolph Hearst.
Ready and willing
to hunt the great white whale?
Just call me Ahab.
-Do come in.
-At this rate, you'll never finish.
You said 90 days. Welles said 60.
I'm doing the best I can.
I've put up with your suicidal drinking,
your compulsive gambling,
your silly platonic affairs.
You owe me, Herman.
Who do you think you are?
You're nothin' but a court jester.
What I wanna know is what you think of it.
It's a bit of a jumble.
A collection of fragments
that leap around in time
like Mexican jumping beans.
Welcome to my mind, old sock.
Him, I get. But what did Marion
ever do to deserve this?
It's not her!
Not all characters are headliners.
Some are secondary.
You pick a fight with Willie,
you are finished.
Mayer can't save you. Nobody can.
Especially the boy genius from New York.
I removed any distraction,
eliminated every excuse.
Your family, your cronies, liquor.
I gave you a second chance.
You cannot capture
a man's entire life in two hours.
All you can hope is to leave
the impression of one.
Why Hearst?
Outside his own blonde Betty Boop,
you were always
his favorite dinner partner.
Are you familiar with the parable
of the organ grinder's monkey?